brave start play tonight 74 and 65 on
the season three and a half games now in
front of the philadelphia phillies ian
anderson ready to go to work against the
marlins
one two he just struck out jazz chisholm
have a seat
got him with a change up and two down
one ball and two strikes
and this one is a tapper anderson can't
come up with the play and de la cruz
will reach to extend the inning a two
out base knock for brian de la cruz here
at the top of the first inning brings
jesus sanchez to the plate
duo pitch
is it in the air and
long gone i'll tell you what
solaire didn't even move that ball was
crushed a two-run home run for jesus
sanchez after the little dribbler keeps
the inning alive and it's two-nothing
now that's how you silence a crowd in
atlanta trevor rogers his 22nd start of
the season
second lowest e-r-a among major league
rookies
0-2 pitch from rogers and he dials up 98
at the top of the zone maybe a little
even above that
and a called strike three on the outside
corner two up and two down both by way
of the k
driven toward left that's well hit
alfaro twisting turning can't get it the
ball at the base of the wall freddie
freeman on his way to second hit number
28 against the marlins that was a thing
of beauty
but there is a strikeout rogers comes
back
here's the one two got him swinging
strike three throw that around the horn
no grind for ian anderson four
strikeouts in his first two innings a
league high in the national league 99
rbis one-two pitch swing gonna miss he
got him another change up that time
that's off the glove miggy on the
backhand and makes the play over in
first
we'll tap her back to anderson knocks it
down and then he can't get a handle on
it zazi moves to the first base side of
the bag
and de la cruz didn't get that a swing
and a miss five strikeouts for anderson
jazz goes
and darno couldn't get a handle on it
another stolen base for jazz good jump
by jazz that is his 20th stolen base
this year
sanchez draws the walk
jabs from second sanchez from first will
be off with the 3-2 pitch that misses
low and they will be loaded for leiwan
diaz another shift defensively for the
braves on an o2 pitch
and it's lifted to the left side
playable for austin reilly
and riley and foul ground makes the play
and anderson gets out of the third
one two from rogers and he goes to the
changeup for the strikeout that's number
five
as anderson heats up jackson and strikes
him out for the second time
that one good enough and seven
strikeouts for ian anderson
that is past a couple of braves and into
right field jazz has himself a one out
single in the fifth
that's a ground ball base hit into left
field jazz was off on the pitch and he
will get to third easily
marlins have him on the corners here in
the fifth inning
another multi-hit effort for brian de la
cruz another one too
a swing and a miss
big strikeout that has been that kid's
kryptonite pj good choice good time for
a strikeout 122 average on breaking
balls
the pitch swung on missed
elevated the here gets the strikeout and
strands a pair
that ball's hit to right darnold's gonna
get that one down off the roll
and he's gonna chug towards second
helmet flying he's in the braves have
their second hit it's their second
double and the tying run comes to the
plate 3-0 count
and garcia takes ball four braves have
their first inning with two base runners
oh he got hit well that's one way to do
it and now eddie adrianza is going to
come on and pinch it
hot shot base hit brazer on the board
one run is in rc around third they'll
stop him a two-strike hit from andy
adrianza and the braves are back in the
game
zach thompson takes over this will be
his 17th game this season two and two
here it comes swinging to miss and
thompson gets the strikeout two outs in
the inning it's up to solaire gonna look
for a ball out over the plate
sharply head and throw base in one run
scores heredia streaks around ball
dropped by dana cruz here comes adrianza
[Applause]
is rocking 4-2 atlanta batter is freeman
first pitch and a cue shot by freddie
thompson can't get it charging hard at
third band
another one will score solaire is in
freeman the second two marlins errors
now shawn nukem will follow ian anderson
he has leads at first
and there's a good sequence he struck
him out
and a blazing fastball inside corner
newcomb struck out the three hitters
after the diaz infield hit
pop into shallow center chisholm going
back and makes a try at it and the ball
dropped
[Applause]
[Music]
duvall will be safely at second after
darnold walks first and second nobody
out here we go again three and two
all right another pop-up where's this
one gonna go
no netting to be found jackson
underneath it drifting back into fair
territory to make it
and he just got a strikeout as rojas
couldn't pull the trigger
five straight strikeouts by the braves
relief court newcomb three jackson toot
did he go yes he did he tied him right
up
leywin line drive that is going to get
down solaire cuts it off before it can
get into the gap but a two out base hit
for lewin diaz
multi-hit effort for him reiner at first
in a three-run game the pitch
he got him four strikeouts for jackson
atlanta has a 5-2 lead we head to the
homemade
it's a fair ball long throw diaz
legs out in field head
and the lefty tries again and misses
badly outside this ball four love to see
rc get a hit here get that confidence
going
has that one smoked up the middle of
base head here comes riley the third
they're gonna wave him home here comes
the throw it is up the line garcia is
going to take second as the ball gets by
alex jackson
not a safe situation for will smith but
a little lower leverage situation for
will
already is under it he's got it and the
braves win
will smith a one two three nine